[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored
probably had a better ski outfit though
I bet I still have the same one I can't
do it
no Starstruck lawyers courtroom
theatrics an oscar-winning A-list are
accused of skiing recklessly is the
trial of Gwyneth Paltrow the most
bizarre and pointless celebrity showdown
in history alask that queen of Common
Sense Sharon Osborne and will pay
tribute to the late great Paul O'Grady
for authenics bands transgender athletes
from Elite competition should all other
sports now follow or debate that
thus is harrowing details emerge on a
national school shooting which left
three nine-year-olds dead I'm gonna ask
two Americans is this now the new normal
for your country more children get
killed by guns every year in America
than anything else now
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening Fernando welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored there's a
common assumption that the world is
inevitably going nuts the list of books
Brands movies songs ideas products
people and words deemed offensive grows
ever longer those of us huddle together
on the tiny island of Common Sense will
be gradually submerged by the rising
tide of lunacy until the two spirit
penguins are in charge of the zoo but
recently I've been feeling the little
green shoots of optimism
there's a recovery from Oklahoma there's
a growing dossier of evidence that
actually most people don't think like
these idiots and have had enough of all
the woke nonsense at the end of last
week's Sebastian code the president of
the world Athletics Council one of
Britain's greatest athletes made this
announcement
the council has agreed to exclude male
to female transgender athletes who have
been through male puberty from female
world ranking competitions from March
the 31st
well Hallelujah uh how's it taking this
long athletes born male with their
bigger stronger male bodies and Superior
muscle mass cannot compete against women
fairly it's just not equal that's a
victory for common sense last month the
British prime minister Richard sune
startled me by saying this
the world's most controversial question
bizarrely has become what is a woman
yeah I of course I know a woman who's
adult human female
incredible that was a question that
stumped secure Stam leader of the
opposition is stumped Supreme Court
justices in America is stump poor old
Nicholas sturgeon who's now lost her job
because she just couldn't work out what
a woman is
a politician finally having the guts to
actually say the obvious and not worry
about being condemned immediately is
ambitious bigger because he's not
another victory of your common sense the
shocking case of Isla Bryson the double
rapist who transitioned to become a
woman after after reaching trial and
then demanded a place in a female prison
where he would have been surrounded by
people he could then attack as he had
done before United the country in
disbelief
only Nicholas sturgeon the first
minister of Scotland didn't get that
memo
trans women are women but in the present
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman there are context where
our trans women is not a woman no there
is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate
excruciating to watch one of the most
successful women in modern politics
literally end her career by not being
able to stand up for women's rights and
that complete failure of basic Common
Sense led to her departure well days
later one of the titans of British
policies was on the clinical Scrappy
it's not a lesson for everybody else if
you go against Common Sense eventually
there will be a day of reckoning this
week's student to the U.S University
have been protesting the decision to
invite the state's Governor Glenn
Younkin potentially one of the
presidential candidates for next year to
make a speech his crime is being a
republican he's actually a reasonably
moderate Republican six thousand of
these snowflake students have signed the
petition to stop it
but remarkably instead of bowing to this
juvenile mob who just want to sit in
their little tank talking to each other
about the same things that they all
agree on as we've become accustomed to
they've gone ahead and invited him
anyway
another victory for common sense and
when reporters discovered that so-called
sensitivity readers were purging classic
novels by Royal darling Fleming Agatha
Christie and so on cleansing them even
Eden blight and got brought into this
cleansing them of apparently upsetting
content the public said no shut up stop
this madness
we couldn't find anybody to come on this
show to defend it finally the penny is
dropping and then we have the guardian
the global home of History bashing logic
defying virtue signaling wokery who've
now had to issue a groveling massive
front page apology for itself for being
a bunch of racists founded by somebody
who employed slaves
which even the most humorless hard mode
signal as a virtue had been forced to
admit is actually very entertaining and
amusing for the rest of us and even
Hollywood seems to be finally stirring
too today Jennifer Aniston lamented the
fact publicly that many young people say
friends was offensive
the number of people saying
I can't believe it but I actually agree
with Piers Morgan is reaching historic
levels
it's getting very busy on Common Sense
Island
I think we're going to need a bigger
boat
well I'm joined now by the perfect
person actually talk to the presenter
Superstar great friend of mine Sharon
Osborne love you pierce if you know what
how we've had to fight this fight and
it's felt a lonely battle hasn't it I
mean just for basic common sense and I
always say to people I think 90 of the
public have always agreed with me and
you about this kind of stuff
um but there's this sort of huge
megaphone on social media which skews
what people believe is the mass thinking
yeah and also that people you know
goes against wokeness you get barrage
with assaults you know on your social
media your life you just get you know a
barrage by you know crazies they're
threads we both have them yeah we both
had death threats for expressing
honestly held opinions it won't remotely
racist transphobic sexism or any of it
we aren't those things but you've got to
be able to challenge stuff in a
democracy otherwise if you don't what
are we we're not a democracy anymore are
we nope not at all and you know as far
as women go I think it was Alice Cooper
who wrote Only Women Bleed right I mean
would you this whole thing where
politicians like Nicholas sturgeon who
was an amazing Trailblazer for women's
politics right and became a massively
successful first minister of Scotland
but got frozen into this trap but hold
on hold on is it just me but when I
first read about this criminal who'd
gone back to Austin pink and had the
worst wig I'd ever seen anyway it looked
like his mum had dressed him up he was
scamming everybody he was scamming his
ex-wife his ex-wife came out of the
woodwork he said and said the guy's just
trying it on of course he's a
transgender he just doesn't want to be
put in a male prison as a rapist he's
about counselor and a thief and
everything else but the thing is it's
like who could see that everybody but
60 of all the trans uh prisoners in
Scotland apparently something like 60
yeah well no they only transitioned
after their conviction yes of they did
because they want to get out of a male
prisonership and get into the easier
female prison it's to get out of jail
free card isn't it and that's always
been my point about it is it you've got
to start from a position of protecting
women's rights and women and you don't
do that by allowing rapists and sex
offenders to put their hands up and say
actually I'm a woman and then get put
with women who they can attack that's
the opposite of protecting them it's
it's insanity and who couldn't see that
this guy is taking the piss out of the
system look at him I know he turned out
Nicholas sturgeon couldn't yeah because
she tried in a torturous way to defend
it and actually in the end she lost the
support of the people of Scotland
because they all most of them just I
mean I've been to Scotland a lot I love
Scotland I love the people and they were
like what the hell are you talking about
look at him look at him he's winding you
up he's a scam artist like look and it's
the same with sport you know this this
big thing by said that finally they're
going to get to grip through this
because it's not about not wanting trans
gender athletes to have a chance to
compete they should be able to but they
should either compete against their own
biological sex so if you were born a
male right biological you can't dispute
science if you're born a male and you
transition to compete against man
right without having shoulders this big
feet this big and you're going in to
swim against somebody that's five foot
two we saw that that Leah Thomas the one
you're six foot three very much
powering over her Rivals of the podium I
couldn't look at it she won one Race by
56 seconds
it was in insanity and it's like how can
you not like look at this Podium picture
and you see I I don't blame Leah Thomas
Lea Thomas has transitioned fair enough
I respect that I don't mind calling Leah
Thomas Lear she that's fine but I do
object to these women trying to catch
her who've got no chance just because of
their biology she's looking down on
everybody it's like look yeah I don't
blame her for for doing what she did but
you're absolutely right put him with the
man well we're going to debate that
later I want to talk about one woman who
may be almost indefensible at this stage
which is Gwyneth Paltrow this this case
this is all over three hundred thousand
dollars I'm like what are you doing why
would she let me go to court and not
settle let's have a little look at some
of the highlights or low lights
um may I ask how tall you are I'm just
under 5 10. okay I am so jealous I think
I'm shrinking though you and me both I
have to wear four inch heels just to
make it to five five so they're very
nice oh thank you I was yelling at him
pretty loud
I was pretty upset right you're small
But Mighty
actually you're not that small
and you're not trained in accident
reconstruction
me yeah no neither am I you were wearing
goggles a helmet yes okay it kind of
looked like everybody else on the slope
that's always my intention okay probably
had a better ski outfit though I bet I
still have the same one
what am I watching this is a court of
law
where's the bucket and my favorite
moment was when she was asked about what
what she'd lost from this terrible
incident she went well half a day skiing
it's like what no I know let's watch
this here we are
and he has deterred you from enjoying
the rest of what was a very expensive
vacation
well I lost
half a day of skiing
nice
okay
what are we watching why is she letting
me I met Gwyneth a couple of times I
actually like her personally but a lot
of people have come out and spoke quite
disparaging about it Dylan Jones our
friend ranji keeps when he did a
nightmare experience with the trying to
interviewer I interviewed her she was
very very very pleasant yeah so I just I
just can't understand what part of her
is wanted to contest this I don't get it
I just I've thought to myself why
doesn't she just let her insurance
company deal with it she's insured
against lawsuits yes you know just just
let them deal with it back down why why
are you doing it has it been that
bad of an experience that you feel that
you want to be heard now it's crazy I
just don't understand I mean they're all
Bonkers in there yeah the guy was that
the screeching sound it's like we're
watching something what size shoe are
you taking it's right who gives up what
size shoe you are Madam who are you
anyway you know I bet you had an
expansive skis I mean what was she doing
is the most bizarre case anyway I mean
there's not gonna be any winner even if
she wins she loses right and she wants a
pound or something and then cosplay it's
all things Preposterous
um on a more serious and sad Point Paul
O'Grady
um I want to show a little Tim he died
at age 67 uh overnight suddenly
um incredibly sad actually he was really
I mean there aren't many people I think
live up to the phrase National Treasure
in Britain but he's probably right up
there let's take a little clip of uh of
Paul
because at least with Aussie the only
cots made would be the effort and
blinding from his speech that's all
pretty nice though Portuguese red from
the allentasia which is basically the
subtle heart of Portugal before you get
to the Algarve Alan Teja
so Timmy you know what she said when
you're up
[Applause]
Foster died on Thursday night he was
little to a cancer he had cancer in his
neck and his face and a tumor in his leg
and the kindest thing for me to do was
to let him go well whatever you're our
boss you're gone but not forgotten kid
give him a big
well and that's now the case for Paul
himself uh he was a great Entertainer
unbelievably funny completely outrageous
a bit like you when you spent time with
Paul O'Grady he would say the most
incredible things but always with a
cackle and a laugh
warm-hearted incredibly good broadcaster
but had a unique ability to just make
people laugh both on camera and off and
adore him you could I'd have never met
anyone that doesn't adore didn't adore
Paul he's such a just an unbelievable
human being loved his dogs like you it
was a it was a good man and there's a
we've actually got a lot to be grateful
to Paul for or by default it's a story
not many people know but I finished
newspapers rather suddenly and uh Simon
Cowell came up with this idea for a a
talent show and he wanted to call it got
talent and he went to ITV here in the UK
and they came up with putting it around
a vehicle around Paul O'Grady called it
Paul O'Grady's Got Talent so we all went
down to do a pilot huge success me Simon
Cowell and fern Britain who was then
doing uh this morning
and the contestants were the audience
and it was a great hit and ITV we're
going to launch this in Prime Time
massive thing for Paul massive thing for
me this was my big TV breakthrough and
at the last minute Paul fell out
spectacularly with ITV you and I of
course would never behave like this
never had a massive falling out with
them call them a bunch of petty tyrants
and said I'd rather be sweeping the
streets the work for ITV which brought
an Abrupt 10 to my dream and the show
and then Simon Cowell sold the rights to
America to NBC they repackaged it as
America's Got Talent I went on that you
then joined it after a season number one
show in America and who knows that may
have never happened if Paul hadn't had a
strop with ITV yeah and walked off and
he had a great great career over at um
Americans got talent with the Hof and uh
Harry and various others um so it was a
a great talent and will be greatly
missed I think obviously Irreplaceable
yeah there's nobody that could you know
walk in his shoes he's just an
incredible human being well he's the
kind of guy I always think there's two
types of broadcasting uh especially for
live television they're the type that
when something goes wrong they they're
paralyzed they can't do anything they
just can't move and there are the types
like Paul O'Grady who would Revel in
stuff like falling off his chair or
something going wrong he'd find it
hilarious and he would communicate his
hilarity to the audience who would then
all fall about laughing because and
that's a real talent real that's it
that's the difference between fake and
real well he's authentic and I always
think you and I have had this discussion
before but authenticity is the key I
think on television if people can see
through you eventually if you try and
pretend to be someone you're not they'll
see through it and Paul was exactly what
you saw on television was what you saw
when you met him exactly all Hearts yeah
great guy uh loved his dogs loved his
fans loved his viewers and he'll be
greatly missed um Sharon lovely to see
you how how he referenced Aussie
everyone references Aussie how is Aussie
he's good he's he's doing so much better
he's
um I think I told you about it the other
night but now it's been announced we can
talk about it he's doing a show October
6 in America he's doing
um
and he's there and it's going to be a
great show Guns and Roses Metallica racy
DC Aussie so the rock is Still rocking
we're going to worry about Aussies no no
he never stopped he'll he's he's back
please send him my best
he wants to talk to you well let's talk
all right I'm available my answering
machine says if that's Aussie I'm here
all right that's right I'd love to talk
to you okay great to see you love you
well coming next tonight as we discussed
earlier World Athletics bands trans
athletes from Elite competition should
every sport now follow to protect the
Integrity of women's School
thank you
[Music]
very beloved let us bright they're
careful doing praying too exactly
there's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read a
book
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
welcome back to piersburg nonsense the
massager of trans athletes competing in
women's sport appears to be nearing what
I would say is a common sense conclusion
at least for now images like this a
transgender swimmer Leah Thomas that we
discussed earlier kind of crystallize
the absurdity in our fairness well
certainly that's what I think well hope
high profile stories of Laurel Hubbard
who made the Tokyo Olympics as a trans
weightlifter at the age of 43 nearly
double the age of any of the other
female contestants smart Furious debate
well last week World Athletics announced
that trans athletes will no longer be
allowed to compete against women from
the end of this month they did it to
protect fairness and integrity of
women's sport critics said it's
transphobic that's their response to
anything in this in this debate and
leaves trans women with nowhere to go
which is a fairer argument which has to
be resolved but joining me now is
British Opera Champion Emilia strickler
and human rights campaigner Peter tatto
welcome to both of you um Amina we had
you on before about this and you were
very passionate about why this needed to
happen so I'd imagine you've really been
pleased to see this development hundred
percent were a lot of women especially
in athletics are really really excited
about this it's just about now making it
go into Grassroots and Masters level
where there is a lot of trans women
competing in the women's category as
well so now that we've got the elite
level it needs to be all levels all
sports so Peter it's complex this
because I don't want trans athletes not
to be able to compete let me just say
that straight away but I spent some time
with Martina Navratilova in Florida last
week who's been recovering from double
cancer and it's very moving interview
but we actually had a chat about this as
well because she's one of the most high
profile lgbtq campaigners has ever been
And yet when she raised her head over
the parapet about this and said I just
think it's a real problem and you can't
allow this to continue otherwise women's
sport will be destroyed she then got
tried to be canceled and people abused
her they shamed her and so on which I
thought was completely ridiculous the
idea she's not a friend of the
transgender Community because she's
trying to stand up for what she saw was
an fairness for women's rights in spool
and I just thought that was terrible
what do you make of this ruling by
Sebastian Co and what Athletics and how
do we resolve all this well the first
principle is that Ford has to be fair
and it's not fair if people have
particular unique advantages so you
would accept that well I accept that but
I would also accept that not all trans
athletes are the same so some may have
an advantage and others may not so for
example I know a woman a trans woman who
competes in a women's football team I'm
on the team she is one of the smallest
and weakest of the team no one can say
that she has an unfair advantage and
equally all athletes in Elite Sports
have some kind of Advantage they may
have extra large lungs or Hearts A Long
Legs tall height Michael Phelps that
fantastic brilliant swimmer who won so
many gold medals in the pool had it on
feasibly large wingspan yeah and right
when he put his arms out it was six
inches longer than anybody else's
reached so but he also had extra large
lung capacity right so I've heard such
Feats yeah I I think you know it's not
an invalid argument I mean they're you
know in All Sport you're going to get
some people who are physical freaks if
all of a better phrase like Michael
Phelps who literally could do this and
it's normally the same as your height or
something the span and he had six inches
extra massive hands right obviously you
can help him and huge feet I think as
well what's what's your response to that
argument but biologically they're still
the sex that they're competing against
um you know at the end of the day
reducing a testosterone level is is not
going to cut it because women are so
much more than a testosterone level you
know physiologically you know periods
whole other whole other well that is
certainly not to be you know like it's
we're so much more than a testosterone
level so just reducing a testosterone
level at the end of the day I mean it's
not going to change the physiological
difference there's a lot of these people
too are you know they're training as a
male athlete for a long period of time
before transitioning so they're having
lung capacity as well all these things
which you get after having gone through
puberty they're real things which give
most most trans athletes a an immediate
biological advantage that's my problem
the other half of this is what what if
if they don't compete against women born
to female bodies what happens to trans
athletes now I think there's one of two
things you can do either they compete
against their biological sex which most
of them have done anyway for many years
is actually never successfully they do
when they compete against women which I
think is the argument right there or you
create an entirely new category there
are more and more as you said at
Grassroots level you create an entirely
new category for Trans athletes to
compete against other trans athletes
well my starting point is there
shouldn't be a blanket ban on all trans
athletes there should be individual
assessment so where there are issues
that's never going to work as well no of
course it can you can't make it one you
know person by person by person by
person you can't they're not that many
trans athletes overall and it's quite
actually there are more and more of them
well there are but there's still a very
thirteen in Elite Athletics DSD athletes
so 13 Elite as you see what my issue
with this they're going to start
breaking women's records irrevocably
because I mean Leah Thomas won One race
against females that's you know just a
point of the argument females by 50 odd
seconds I mean it was ridiculous and
then at the podium Tower's over these
these this Podium picture you can't no
one can be happy about that yeah that is
clear advantage or a biological male
what I'm saying where there is a clear
demonstrable proven Advantage an unfair
Advantage then of course that should not
be allowed to take place but I do think
that individual assessment rather than a
blanket ban is the way to go okay
because then you you don't you penalize
the ones who do have an unfair Advantage
but you don't penalize that ones that
don't so Amelia it's interesting because
in in rugby I think in places like new
zealands now for example they do
actually because they recognize that
some kids when they get to 13 are twice
the size of other 13 year old kids they
now separate them in weight classes
rather than age so they put the ones who
are a certain size and they they play
rugby against each other depending it's
no longer about age
so it's what Peter says he got any Merit
to do it this way I mean I I I I don't
think me or many female athletes would
think that was still appropriate because
of the biological sex that is there at
the end of the day yeah there's still so
many physiological differences
you know they're never going to have a
period right whereas every Elite female
athlete once a month has but in some
cases quite a crippling condition which
they're going to get every month which
will affect their training will affect
professions competitions right which I
completely understand when women say
that that's not going to happen to a
trans athlete no it won't so they have
that Advantage regardless of their size
yeah but again I say
don't have a blanket van have individual
assessment I think it's particularly
unfair for intersex athletes like Casa
semenya well that's a different case but
but it's very similar because it's about
you know a mixture of male and female
and it's not something they have chosen
it's something I do feel I I feel it's
not like the the rapist situation
Scotland where I think they're literally
scamming the system I do have respect
for people who transition it's not about
being transphobic at all it's about
Caster didn't transition she was born no
I know I know I I think that's a
different case but I I think that
they're very very unique cases I mean
there's hardly any of them right well
there's the 13th that's the number in
terms of Casa smart DSD yeah sorry that
was the number I I was referring to 13
DSD athletes in the women's distance
events and three of them had
gold silver and bronze in 2016 Olympics
so I mean we're you know clearly they
have an advantage because they've done
really really well for themselves well
they might just be very good athletes
but you know I I take them there's a
debate going on here yeah and I think we
need more science more investigation and
I do think as I said it has to be fair
for old Athletics said we've seen the
science this is why we've made our
decision we've seen the science Peter I
like your attempt to try and win this
argument but I think I don't agree even
Lord codes said he did Even though kohe
said it's not proven that they don't
have an advantage so you know it's it's
a negative that Lord Co and the world
Athletics Federation are seeking to
uphold and I think that's a very bad way
to go maybe but I think the best way to
do is to is to say stop pause continue
investigating but for now preserve the
Integrity of women's sport right I mean
I mean that's where I think please give
us a shot yeah please and your case
literally literally yes
thank you both very much well coming
next to that is more harrowing details
emerge about the national school
shooting which left three nine-year-old
children dead is this now The New Normal
in America
is this what it's going to be like a
million new guns sold in America every
month a million how does this end
without endless more shootings I'll
debate that with two Americans who have
very different news after the break
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
well three nine-year-old children and
three adults arrived at the Covenant
School a small private Christian Academy
in Nashville Tennessee on Monday for
what should have been a normal day but
by the afternoon all six of them were
dead they were killed by Audrey Hale a
transgender shooter who had seven
legally held weapons including assault
style rifles guns are now the leading
cause extraordinary statistic the
leading cause of death for children and
teens in America clearly it can't go on
like this but how on Earth does it not
go on like this given that a million new
guns are sold every month in America and
this situation is getting worse all the
time well it's not for me to tell
Americans what to do with their gun laws
or their gun culture but Americans have
to sort it out down that they can't just
keep letting schools being attacked like
this so I'm going to bring together two
Americans with very different views to
see if we can somehow find some common
ground which might POS possibly do
something to help the situation I'm
joined by Fox News host and lawyer
harada Rivera and conservative talk show
Radio Star Ben Ferguson well welcome to
both of you Geraldo um I'd look at your
tweets whenever these things happen and
I'll sort of share your general I think
dismay that nothing ever seems to get
done about this and I've seen you
arguing with people about it but there's
a real Groundhog Day feel now to this
where if the number of guns in
circulation exponentially Rises all the
time and there are no new gun laws
brought in then how does anyone expect
this to not just get worse
I just keep wondering peers when
too much will be enough to motivate
people to change the Grim reality there
are more guns in this country now than
there are people there's been 130 mass
shootings since the first of the year it
is a horrifying uh situation the gun
lobby is so overwhelmingly powerful it
intimidates anyone who speaks out
against it as you yourself experienced
during your time here in the state's
Piers it is uh powerful it is uh you
know
formidable it is very difficult to move
you know they tend to to duck down and
stay out of sight for the uh for the raw
impact of one of these particularly
gruesome uh uh experiences then they
resurface and fight off any any changes
the state of Tennessee where this latest
shooting happened uh anyone can have a
gun anyone we can have a concealed
weapon there are no laws against it
unless you are deranged or have some
court order against you neither of which
uh Audrey Hale had so we'll have more
and more of these it'll happen again and
again and again we'll be horrified for a
day or so and then move on it's a it's a
situation there this this is the cancer
in America and I don't know how you fix
it Pierce Ben Ferguson you and I have
debated this I think for I don't know uh
14 years a decade a 14 14 years probably
since I joined CNN yeah you know Sandy
Hook I felt at the time surely would
change everything and nothing changed
and then we had exactly the same number
of kids killed very recently in a mass
shooting at a school very similar to
Sandy Hook 20 again and I realized this
was really Groundhog Day and why should
it change when actually nothing gets
done I simply ask you one question I
think which is I understand and the
Second Amendment I understand that you
believe like many Americans millions of
Americans that you have a right to bear
arms okay and I understand you can't
take away 400 million guns there's too
many of them out there what I don't
understand is why the rights of children
not to be shot dead which they're now
being done in more numbers than any
other cause of death while those rights
are not deemed to be above your right to
have an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle
uh let's start number one with the
Constitution shall not be infringed
means shall not be in French so that's
the first thing and that's in our
constitution second thing is this we can
never change Ben
hang on the only Ben on that point on
that point it's the Second Amendment
right right but why can't it be amended
there have been 27 amendments to your
Constitution why can't it be brought up
to speed with the reality of modern
America because the founding fathers
peers understood shall not be infringed
needed to be used because and I'm going
to explain it
yesterday all of the media the day
before saying it was AR-15 that was used
it was not an AR-15 that was used in
fact the only AR-15 Piers that was used
in this shooting was by the police
officer who took down the shooter the
shooter she had a carbine it was either
a nine millimeter or a 40 caliber which
is a handgun that is the same exact
caliber so the question is if we're
gonna have an honest conversation about
this then you have to say and know what
you're talking about there's also
something else that's not true people
have been saying the number one cause of
death in America of young people is gun
violence that is a lie they counted 18
and 19 year olds to get the number to be
higher than it was over fentanyl if you
want to talk about saving kids lives
then be intellectually honest about it
and don't cook the books on the numbers
the number one killer in America right
now of young people is fentanyl
overdoses it is not gun violence they
counted 18 year olds as an adult and 19
year olds which are adults so that's the
second thing so if you want to fix the
problem then we can't let's start with
lies the third thing appears is this
what you just heard a moment ago from
Geraldo was also a lie about my home
state of Tennessee the idea that
everyone can have a gun that is a lie I
own a gun store in Tennessee I train
law-abiding citizens to protect and
defend themselves people bring us
cookies and brownies because they're
able to save their own lives afterwards
would you have sold this woman seven
weapons hold it then would you have sold
would you have sold the shooter in
Nashville seven weapons would you have
great in your store when you sell your
cookies and your tea would you have
allowed this person with emotional
problems to purchase answer the question
if you're gonna ask it let me answer the
question
the gun laws are clear here she did not
break any laws before she broke the laws
yesterday that would take away her
rights to own a gun now if we didn't
sell her a weapon then you would have
said we're profiling somebody in the
lgbtqi plus community and how dare you
believe me they're right baloney seven
weapons seven weapons at what point at
what point does the does a prudent
normal ordinary gun seller to the 26
year old 28 year old wait this is the
sixth weapon I've told you this week
this is the seventh weapon I've sold you
this week
what do you think she's gonna do with it
seven weapons in a week the way you
describe it you're being disingenuous
and you're full of crap if you want to
learn something and come to a compromise
and listen and don't just say something
you know nothing about in Tennessee if
you come in to buy a gun we have the
right if we think you're under the
influence mentally unstable or you have
a problem or you seem like you're
depressed or you've seen that you're
under the influence of anything to say
no we say no to people all the time
let me jump in she bought seven Firearms
guns different types in five different
stores and this happens time and again I
would ask you this Ben I remember a time
I think it may not be the case now but
certainly for many years I couldn't buy
a Kinder surprise chocolate egg in
America they were my favorites they were
chocolate eggs with little toys inside I
couldn't buy them because they were
banned across the United States in fact
I know a former British prime minister
who tried to bring some into America and
had them confiscated at LAX airport
because one of them for his nephews and
he couldn't bring them in they were
banned they were banned because there
was a risk that a child might choke on
the little toy inside the chocolate sure
and yet at the same time there are
people all over America wandering around
arming themselves like Rambo I don't get
that how can a Kinder surprise chocolate
egg have more restrictions than
semi-automatic rifles explain
I I would go to the real core of the
issue here we have a mental health
problem right now in this country and
people don't want to talk about that
issue you have a woman here who we have
normalized the mental health issue
because we're playing politics did you
know the World Health Organization
before all of the pressure came in to
get rid of a quote stigma around
transgenderism used to categorize it as
a mental health issue
wait wait wait wait wait hold on
you don't think you don't think we have
chocolate you don't think we have
mentally ill people in Britain you don't
think they have any space
I'm trying to make
this is the problem if you want to talk
about mental health then let's talk
about mental health she was obviously
dealing with serious mental health
issues and we shouldn't normalize mental
health to check Boxes by saying that and
what about the shooter in Uvalde what
about the shooter in Buffalo what about
the shooter in Parkland this is again
mental health issues or mental health
every week every week we get one of
these mass killings Pierce let me just
say one thing what is clear from what
had just this tragedy that has struck an
uh stricken the national in the rest of
the United States the the thing that
distinguishes it unlike Uvalde the
officers were Brave courageous bold
selfless they ran to the uh to the
shooter rather than running away from
the shooter that's the the Second
Amendment is stupid as currently
construed by the courts we have to live
with it however because there's no way
it's ever going to be uh rescinded but
one thing we can do is when people have
the uh the the the the the sickness the
obscenity to go and perpetrate violence
with Firearms let the cops go let's go
let's go go in guns blazing
I thought at least be distinguished by
that yeah I thought they were extremely
courageous those police officers
indirect well hang on in direct contrast
to what happened to the valade well
there were hundreds of them there were
just a bunch of cowards look I've got to
leave it there all I would say uh Ben uh
I mean Geraldo thank you for saying what
you're saying because it's not a popular
thing to do in America but at some point
Ben Americans have got to do more than
they're doing I don't know I mean you
probably maybe you don't care about how
the rest of the World Views this but you
are supposed to be the number one
superpower in the world a place we look
up to and respect I love America I love
Americans I just can't get my head
around this gun virus
let me make the point I'm making Ben you
can't just have this going on and on and
on and do nothing you can't yeah Pierce
last year in September there was a bill
before the Senate to add armed security
to every public school not a single
Democrat voted for it because they cared
more about playing politics with with
the gun control laws than they did about
protecting children if you want to
protect these children we do more to
protect money in our banks in America we
do more protectors and we do children in
our school all right I've got to move on
thank both very much indeed Gerardo
thank you Ben thank you very much you
can see you know how passionate this is
in America and how intransigent it is
there's not an inch given
on this debate and nothing has changed
in the 14 years I've been covering mass
shootings in America Sandy Hook was
2012.
it's incredible it's just going on and
on nothing happens well next tonight
should we pause our development of
artificial intelligence and to assure
the robots aren't going to basically
take us over and maybe kill us all I'll
discuss that discuss that with people
currently identifying as humans next
please
[Music]
very beloved let us bright they're
careful who are we praying to exactly
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read a
book hahaha
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
you can't get rid of me please I'm back
at nine o'clock with my lovely panel on
The Talk indeed we are and we'll be
discussing King Charles's State visit to
Germany the government's plans to house
migrants in army barracks and barges
plus find out why the city of Amsterdam
is telling us Rowdy Brits to stay away
all of that and more on the talk at nine
laughs
what a job by my pattern I told to be
contributed to Esther cracker and the
daily mirrors Associated to Kevin
McGuire I want to start with AI I want
to play a clip from an interview I did
with Professor Stephen Hawking this was
the last television interview he gave it
turned out I asked him how would the
world end what was the biggest threat
here's what he said
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it
ever since the start of the Industrial
Revolution there have been fears of mass
unemployment as machines replaced humans
instead the demand for goods and
services has risen in line with the
increased capabilities
whether this can continue indefinitely
is an open question but there is a
greater Danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing for then it can improve
itself rapidly and we may lose control
well very pressing because today a
thousand eminent people between Elon
Musk Bill Gates Steve Wozniak calls the
Apple Genius with Steve Jobs other Tech
leaders call for a pause a six-month
pause in the out of control artificial
intelligence race
warning is a profound risk to society
and Humanity Kevin this is serious stuff
these guys know what they're talking
about and they can see the rapid rate of
progress with AI could lead to exactly
where Professor Hawking was warning yeah
with any technology it is who controls
and benefits from it and if you want a
few corporations to be taking over your
life well that's going to happen and
that's why I see the arguing for the
pause with Elon Musk I say hang on
you've been resisting regulation and not
giving up details of for instance Tesla
systems so he's resisted regulation in
the past but he wants it here but I do I
do think it's right because otherwise
it's gonna have a huge impact on us all
and there's going to be a few big
corporations in control I'm going to say
step and on one level people have been
worried about AI in relation to human
jobs and that's a completely
understandable thing where technology
takes over human Manpower this is a bit
more serious what they're getting at is
what Professor Hawking was warning me
about that time which is actually it
could just take us over yeah they become
so sophisticated that they they
effectively uh just
become they've come too sophisticated to
control I think this is a little bit too
late for this and I think that the
incentive to actually push for AI is the
commercial incentive is too strong to
actually stop it now I mean it's quite
Rich that's coming from someone like
Elon Musk and all of these people who
have basically pushed for this but on
the other hand who else is best better
equipped to Warners than people like
Elon Musk who aren't you get under the
Bonnet these things and know how
dangerous yeah they're concern about
arrival aren't they or they're concerned
about Rivals but I think we should be
concerned now in question their motives
but I think we should be concerned about
who controls and who benefits absolutely
and I you know you don't want to stop
human Ingenuity but when they're genuine
threats to humanity I think that's where
you have to draw the line we're talking
about genuine threat to humanity The
Guardian newspaper which is a genuine
threat to humanity
um they've had to issue this
extraordinary front page groveling lead
story apology I mean quite extraordinary
apologizing for the fact their founder
was up to his neck in right in racism
and slavery the un's responded and said
that they wanted the UK government and
the royal family now to start groveling
as well Esther I don't really get all
this well I mean are we really saying
now that in the modern day we had to
spend our entire time atoning for the
sins of generations and generations ago
I mean the only people concerned with
this are the ones I can never atone
enough I'm just hoping that I get a cut
of the the lovely check that the
guardian is going to cut black people
for for their work and slavery but if I
never seem to benefit from it me and my
friends never get money from it which is
very weird by the end of the day you can
never return enough for something like
this the reality is no slavers or slaves
are alive today to properly pay
reparations to and it's just kind of a
self-defeating argument but they just
keep going on about Kevin it is quite
funny watching The Guardian
self-flagellate like this but there is a
wider point in San Francisco they're
talking about giving five million
dollars to every black person who lives
in San Francisco is reparations for
slavery I just I don't understand how
this could do anything other than create
new problems yeah but I don't think we
should be afraid of discussing it and uh
and discuss it and probing into why why
want all the apologies what do they do
any Institution like they're all family
or company that dates back to the 19th
century the guardian will of profited
from exploitation and it won't just be
slaves
you're going to have relatives and I'm
going to have relatives
right everyone's going to have relatives
who at some point will have employed
slaves right and then I don't I doubt I
have I think I was on the put I don't
really get a tiny violence
I was on the Poor Side of the track I
think we were just maybe you don't know
do you that well if if we if it's found
out I'll say oh they weren't very nice
and they were bad
I'll make sure you get some some Dosh
but you can see an institution like the
guardian right which takes principal
stands I think has to face up to its
history and because the Scott trust has
a lot of cash it can begin to make some
amends
I'd like to see the guardian then
handing out a lot of money to people I
need to see my bank account
very juicy by Monday morning oh there
will be words I would love to have been
in the guardian music because they're so
sanctimonious they're all a bunch of
white virtue singers and by the way most
of them are stinking Rich they've got
about eight properties and millions of
but I would love to have been there when
they were told your whole front page
tomorrow is a groveling apology because
your founder that was a racist slave
owner in the American Civil War The
Guardian backed the South the
Confederacy slave owner so it shouldn't
be a great surprise to those at the
guardian now guys believe it thank you
both very much indeed what are you up to
Keep It Uncensored very important good
night
[Music]
thank you
very beloved let us Pride they're
careful who are we praying to exactly
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember